[Musique]
génération identitaire leurs principes
courage excellence humilité communauté
persévérance identité c'est un sur leur
site internet on peut retrouver ce genre
d'allégations pour tenté de rameuter des
jeunes principalement tu te retrouves
pas dans leurs discours politique pour
toi les chaînes de télévision des beats
le même baratin en continu tu en as et
que des petits prof youtube et les
gauchistes de police et vomissent sur
ton pays et son histoire sur internet au
cinéma dans les séries télé partout on
veut te faire culpabiliser blanc et
héros pour eux tu es de trop génération
identitaire point org
les écrits qui choses encore êtes vous
d'accord avec la dissolution de ce
groupe génération identitaire thaïs
discussion vous êtes là vous êtes la
porte parole de ce groupe puisque vous
étiez venu dans balances ton post est ce
que votre présence dans balances ton
post est ce que le sujet qu'on a fait
nos balances ton post a à jouer ou bien
c'était déjà mis en place avant je ne
pense pas je pense que cela fait déjà
longtemps que les différents
gouvernements ont souhaité 10 ou deux
générations identitaire pour des raisons
politiques notamment et ils n'avaient
ils n'ont pas les outils juridiques en
soit pour le faire puisque nous n'avons
aucune raison valable juridiquement
parlant d' être dissous le fait est que
gérald darmanin annoncé souhaiter
souhaité nous dissoudre la et donc ça
pique à vouloir le faire mais pour la
lancer la procédure
c'est à dire que vendredi soir le
président de génération identitaire a
reçu à son domicile
la lettre qui l'informé de la mise en
place de la procédure de dissolution et
d'ailleurs en fait tous les motifs qui
étaient invoquées n'ont absolument aucun
fondement alors elles sont quand même
assez ridicule je pourrais vous donner
des exemples vous les donnerais
tristesse que forcément aussi qu'ils
avaient voulu être là ce soir c'est
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'on voulait dire à
yassine belattar a également un mode
voilà qui la mode brégeon porte parole
de la république en marche
qu'est ce que vous avez à leur dira mode
surtout voilà pourquoi il faut pas
d'issue autre génération identitaire
parce que ici vous allez voir oui non
oui non mais t'es bien vos pancartes
s'il vous plaît les chéris qu'est ce que
vous avez à dire pourquoi vouliez venir
ce soir en direct
déjà parce que disent ou deux
générations identitaire je pense que
c'est une atteinte grave à la liberté
d'expression à la liberté d'association
et le fait est que juridiquement parlant
vous n'avez pas les outils pour deux
pour dissoudre génération identitaire si
vous le faites c'est évidemment pour des
raisons politiques et idéologiques
d'ailleurs ça rentre dans votre agenda
politique puisque d'un côté vous avez 2
vous avez fait semblant de donner des
gages à la droite en 10 ou dissolvant
baraka city ou le ccf qui sont des
associations islamistes qui ont pour le
coup de réels liens avérés avec le
terrorisme islamiste et donc d'un autre
côté vous voulez donner des gages à la
gauche dont vous avez besoin de cet
électorat donc en dissolvant génération
identitaire alors évidemment vous
choisissiez génération identitaire parce
que ça fait un certain moment que ce que
ce mouvement s'est quand même imposé
comme le mouvement le plus efficace le
plus organisé le plus structuré en tout
cas qu'ils étaient capables de faire
face à enfin tout cas aux noces
opposants politiques et que nos actions
sont efficaces donc voulait frapper
aucun délit d'anti knight rider ce que
font moi comme je vous ai dit adam la
fois un mois j'ai commencé l'interview
vous disant vous prenez pour qui vous
fait parfois et souvent des actions où
vous outrepassez vos droits
je suis désolé vous n'êtes pas vous ne
regardez pas les milliards ou non est ce
que je ne comprends pas c'est qu'en fait
tout simplement nous ce que nous avons
demandé au final c'est justement nous
respectons la loi quand nous sommes
allés au col du portillon tout ce que
nous demandions c'était que la loi soit
appliquée aux migrants clandestins qui
ips que quand même
aux dernières nouvelles franchir une
frontière illégalement pas que sa hanche
irin frontières et ça c'est important
ou alors un ballet j on vous reproche
pas d'avoir une opinion
vous avez le droit d'avoir une opinion
je la partage pas c'est une chose mais
vous avez le droit de la voir en
revanche l'incitation à la haine et
l'incitation au parce qu'en l'occurrence
que j'ai le mien de racisme ça en france
certes est interdit c'est interdit donc
quand vous montez sur le toit d'une
mosquée pour scander des slogans anti me
voyez juste les six mois terminés mais
se fait continuellement le lien un lien
direct des amalgames volontaire entre
d'islam
l'immigrant et le terrorisme ça c'est
interdit ça s'appelle de l'incitation à
la haine
moi je pense thaïs avec toute l'estimé
que j'ai pour vous que j'espère
réciproque qui en fait votre ennemi
c'était votre diffusion dans cette
émission parce qu'objectivement moi ça
fait longtemps que vous suit de par mes
combats et que je vois déjà les
ratonnades médiatique et numérique que
vous faites sur les réseaux sociaux vous
avez une plate forme qui vous supportent
qui s'appelle twitter ou quand vous
chassez des gens n'y a qu'à voir ce qui
s'est passé une semaine avec le maire de
trappes qui aujourd'hui par vos
collaborateurs et quand même menacés de
mort jamais menacé vous ya six mois
quand je passe ici là je sais que
pendant une semaine c'est avoir le droit
ou à démonter pour aller au bout juste
pour aller au bout oui la 6è quelque
chose je pense que quand on a fait cette
émission les gens ont découvert de
manière mainstream parce que c'est le
cas de cette émission ce que vous
faisiez et je pense qu'il ya un côté
icare dans votre association pouvait pas
dire devant des gens notamment un avocat
pas vu pas vu pas pris maintenant vous
avez vu on vous prend vous parlez du ccf
et de barak a city je pense que moi
j'étais totalement contre la dissolution
de ces associations qui sont comme vous
le dites de manière juridique il n'y
avait rien d'illégal
c'est votre sentiment de croire qu'ils
sont allés avec des actions terroristes
par contre vous ce que vous faites c'est
chasser des immigrés sur le col du
montagne où aller au dessus de la mairie
de de la caf de bobigny et dire faut
virer les étrangers après de dire oui
mais le jugement est en cours c'est vrai
moi j'ai eu votre le patron de votre de
la génération d'auditeurs qui m'envoient
tout je suis plus sur twitter j'ai été
viré c'est quand même c'est heavy réussi
à 10 qui dit qui disent il m'avait eu en
face de lui parler mais pas comme ça
mais je rejoins la phrase de cyril un
déjà vous fait peur à qui est de vous
vous prenez pour qui
parce que si aujourd'hui vous voulez
mettre une armure comme au moyen-age
avoir un glaive et décapité les
sarrasins vous pouvez aussi le faire
après je vous cache pas que c'est
difficile d'augmenter dans le métro avec
une armure mais il faut justement
redescendre il ya des lois il ya une
justice on essaye de reconsolider les
liens aussi avec une police avec qui on
a pu avoir des désaccords mais tous les
policiers sont pas si on essaye de
construire mais vous vous accusez pour
détruire et vous voulez quelque chose et
anaïs dites le moi dans les yeux ce que
vous fantasmez c'est non pas de sortir
un canard en bois noir mais vous
fantasmez l'idée d'une guerre civile
avec dakota et les musulmans et de
l'autre côté vous comme les gardiens de
la patrie mais ça je vous le dis pour
faire une guerre faut être deux non ils
nous auraient pas vos gains les à gérer
mais alors vous attendez que thaïs
réponse à l'isthme je suis quand même
toujours assez mal à l'aise avec le fait
que vous puissiez me faire la leçon
mais son moral alors que je sais que
vous avez quand même été interpellés
nombreux soit vous avez sûrement vous
avez été inculpée pour harcèlement moral
de nombreuses reprises dans les deux à
l'étoile scène judiciaires ne l'avons
pas été condamnés nous les électeurs du
rassemblement national à plat qui nous
regardent y ont dévoilé ya tous les cas
tous les bords politiques qui nous
regardent après nom peut pas se mettre à
la place des électeurs
il ya des gens qui souffrent qui ont des
vies qui sont pas les nôtres ont des
liens privilégiés
oui on va pas se mentir il ya des gens
qui ont voté à droite ya des gens qui
ont voté à gauche n ayant que vous êtes
au milieu et je le dis souvent ils sont
toujours dans la même merde hein car
moment on peut pas se mettre à leur
place et on peut pas donner des leçons
je dirais jamais mis en beauté ou pour
qui ne pas voter parce que voilà je vous
le dis nous on est des privilégiés et il
faut se mettre à la place de gens qui
ont beaucoup beaucoup de difficultés et
qui s'en sortent pas mal d années et des
années qui ont voté pour tous les partis
et qui sont toujours la même merde et un
moment ils disaient pas écoutés nous eh
ben on va sanctionner aussi les partis
qui ont été vus ils ont tort sur toxine
peut pas se mettre à leur place donc
chacun fait ce qu'il veut maintenant
vous vous êtes un groupuscule moi je le
pense que la meilleure phrase le soir
c'est yassine belattar caddie monty
votre parti politique parce que là vous
outrepassez vos droits et vous voilà
c'est l'exemple à ceux qui s'est
présenté aux élections c'est tout et là
vous serez plus réel voilà